tabubruch obwohl die us wahl noch offen
ist erklärt sich donald trump zum sieger
und will die auszählungen weiterer
stimmen gerichtlich stoppen lassen
besorgt bis fassungslos deutsche
politiker und politikerinnen fast aller
parteien werden trumps rede als angriff
auf die demokratie
todesursache corona die zahl der
verstorbenen in deutschland steigt
markant an
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen am
mittwoch zu einem extrem spannenden
nachrichten tag nach der us-wahl katja
stresow ist auch hier und hat den sport
für sie dabei und sehr viele tore in der
fußball-champions-league schönen guten
abend
es ist gekommen wie befürchtet vor genau
zwölf stunden haben sie geschlossen die
wahllokale in den usa aber alles ist
noch offen
auch wenn sich präsident trump schon
vorzeitig zum sieger erklärt hat obwohl
die stimme noch gar nicht alle
ausgezählt sind in den meisten
bundesstaaten ist das rennen jedoch
entschieden
joe biden hat bisher zwei 127 stimmen
der wahlleute hinter sich donald trump
213 zum sieg sind 270 stimmen nötig
jetzt kommt es auf die ergebnisse in
noch einigen schwer umkämpften staaten
an zum beispiel pennsylvania michigan
und wisconsin wird der sonne wald mit
dem überblick
es ist das eingetreten was donald trump
mehrfach angekündigt hat und viele
befürchtet haben
der us-präsident ruft sich in der
wahlnacht zum sieger aus obwohl noch
nicht alle stimmen ausgezählt sind
hier wird betrug an der nation begangen
wir wollen dass das gesetz korrekt
angewendet wird also ziehen wir vor das
oberste gericht wir wollen dass keine
stimmen mehr gezählt werden
sein kontrahent jo biden reagiert prompt
sollte trump das wahlergebnis vor
gericht anfechten
so würden auch die demokraten mit
eigenen juristischen mitteln dagegen
ankämpfen
der demokrat liefert sich noch in
einigen wichtigen bundesstaaten mit rang
ein kopf an kopf rennen
wir glauben dass wir auf einem guten weg
zum sieg sind wir wussten wegen der noch
nie dagewesenen zahl von briefwahl
stimmen würde es länger dauern
es ist noch nicht vorbei bis jede stimme
ausgezählt ist mancherorts wie hier in
maricopa county arizona wird schon
gefeiert im wüstenstaat einer hochburg
der republikaner führen überraschend die
blauen also die demokraten
ich habe tränen in den augen maricopa
county ist blau geworden
ich bin so aufgeregt wir haben in fast
allen bezirken gewonnen das ist jenseits
seiner wildesten träume in florida
dagegen feiern republikaner eine party
diesen wichtigen schlüssel staat mit 29
wahlmännern hat trump in der tasche ich
bin zuversichtlich dass trump das ganze
land gewinnt wenn nicht wäre ich sehr
überrascht
doch ob es so kommt ist noch offen
im moment hat joe biden eine leichte
führung in den swing states müssen noch
millionen von stimmzettel ausgezählt
werden frühestens dann steht fest wer
tatsächlich ins weiße haus einzieht
elmar theveßen beobachtete in washington
die wahl für uns immer jetzt es ist doch
anders gekommen als vorhergesagt und es
sieht so aus als hätten die demoskopen
diesmal schon wieder daneben gelegen
ja ich glaube die demoskopen haben wir
in drei punkten diese wahl unterschätzt
das eine ist das tatsächlich in den
ländlichen gegenden noch mehr menschen
donald trump gewählt haben als vor vier
jahren das zweite das meer schwarz als
vor vier jahren schon gewählt haben
damals 90 8 prozent anteil national
jetzt sind es 12 prozent und drittens
dass latinos auch stärker donald trump
gewählt haben als vor vier jahren in
florida ganz besonders unten in der
gegend rum miami das hat sicherlich
damit zu tun dass er ihre ängste vor
sozialismus geschürt hat aber insgesamt
kann man sagen dass die demoskopen
gruppen schon richtig lagen dass es sehr
sehr knapp werden würde
und wenn joe biden jetzt ich sage mal
die staaten gewinnen würde wo er derzeit
vorne liegt das sind wisconsin arizona
nevada und michigan
dann hätte er 270 wahl wieder stimmen
aber das traumteam hat soeben eine
neuauszählung in wisconsin gefordert
insofern kann uns das noch über tage
vielleicht wochen beschäftigen
danke und bis gleich wir sprechen uns in
ein paar minuten nochmal
die briefwähler werden also die wahl
entscheiden und das passt donald trump
gar nicht denn erfahrungsgemäß wählen
eher demokraten per brief während
republikaner ihre stimme offenbar lieber
persönlich abgeben
beides ist möglich und beides ist legal
doch nun will der präsident das
auszählen der briefwahlstimmen
gerichtlich stoppen lassen
ob er damit erfolg haben kann erklärt
uns anselm stern
mitten in der laufenden wahlperiode and
die befürchtete wahlschlacht gegen die
briefwahl macht er schon lange heftig
stimmung jetzt kündigt er an vor gericht
zu klagen
wir wollen nicht dass sie um vier uhr
morgens noch irgendwelche stimmzettel
finden und sie auf die liste setzen
wann und wie aus welchen rechtlichen
gründen der supreme court angerufen
werden soll sagt der präsident nicht
bekräftigt nur er wolle lange aus zell
prozesse stoppen
es gibt keine rechtliche grundlage dafür
gültige stimmzettel nicht mehr zu zählen
und sich einfach zum sieger zu erklären
ist kein rechtlicher schritt
es gibt auch keine direkte möglichkeit
den obersten gerichtshof der usa zu
bieten eine auszählung zu beenden
ziel der präsidentin drohung die
laufenden auszahlungen in den
entscheidenden bundesstaaten in manchen
dürfen laut verfassung die
briefwahlunterlagen erst am wahltag
geöffnet werden deswegen dauert ist und
je länger es dauert desto nervöser
werden die republikaner
sie fürchten viele stimmen für joe biden
unter den briefwählern jede stimme muss
gezählt werden auch die
briefwahlunterlagen die mit post
eingangsstempel dritter november noch
eingegangen sind die verantwortlichen
offiziellen vor ort haben auch schon
angekündigt dass das einige tage dauern
könnte dass es rechtlich einwandfrei der
amtierende präsident wolle vor allem
unliebsame wahlergebnisse irgendwie in
zweifel ziehen so experten klagen den
einzelnen bundesstaaten gegen extrem
knappe ergebnisse sehr wahrscheinlich
diese wahlschlacht könnte dauern
schauen wir noch mal genauer auf einen
der staaten die noch offen sind und den
ausschlag geben könnten pennsylvania zum
beispiel da sind bisher 80 prozent der
stimmen ausgezählt und hier führt trump
scheinbar deutlich mit 53,5 zu 45,2
prozent
betrachtet man nur die briefwahlstimmen
dann sieht es anders aus da führt beiden
sehr hoch mit 78,3 prozent
katrin eigendorf ist für uns vor ort in
pennsylvania
kathrin warum sind die dort so hinterher
mit dem auszählen wie lange kann das
denn noch dauern das kann noch bis
freitag dauernden ist sind noch 1,4
millionen stimmen nicht ausgezählt und
es ist nicht nur so dass das annehmen
war zischt im vor allem von demokraten
sind sondern was auch wichtig ist zu
berücksichtigen es sind vor allem die
großen städte wie philadelphia die in
der auszählung sehr hinterher hinken und
philadelphia ist ganz klar eine hochburg
der demokraten
also man sich das alles an guckt und das
berücksichtigt ist berücksichtigt ist
hier in fehler in pennsylvania
eigentlich noch alles offen im rennen
zwischen donald trump und seinem
kontrahenten joe biden
der gouverneur von pennsylvania zum wolf
hat heute nochmal ganz eindringlich die
republikaner gewarnt hier so druck
ausüben und gesagt das ganze was wir
hier erleben
ist ein stresstest für die demokratie
ein bericht von der lage vor ort vielen
dank katrin eigendorf ja und noch mal
zurück zu elmar theveßen da ist er im
moment könnte es tatsächlich noch auf
beiden als präsident hinauslaufen
wie würden denn dann die nächsten vier
jahre aussehen
das würden sehr schwere jahre werden
menschen beiden präsident würde dann
hätte er weniger unterstützung im
abgeordnetenhaus sieht so aus als hätten
die demokraten da einige sitze verloren
und dem senat hätte er eine
republikanische mehrheit mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit wieder gegen sich als
wäre schwer zu regieren und alle
anhänger von trump und trance selber
sind ja nicht weg das heißt das land ist
tief gespalten 50 gegen im grunde
genommen joe biden es wäre eine sehr
schwere regierung so weit sind wir noch
nicht in den nächsten wochen dürfte es
ja diese juristischen herausforderungen
geben und möglicherweise auch der eine
oder andere politische schachzug von
donald trump um vielleicht doch zu
versuchen
wo mit hilfe der republikaner in einigen
bundesstaaten das ist rechtlich möglich
tatsächlich am ende noch präsident zu
werden
vielen dank für die einschätzung trump
oder beiden dazu senden wir ein zdf
spezial gleich ab halb acht und in
unserer zdf heute app finden sie alle
zahlen und fakten rund um die wahl
natürlich und natürlich auch den
neuesten stand dass es so eng werden
würde bei dieser wahl hat viele
überrascht und dass us-präsident trump
sich vorzeitig zum sieger aus ruft sorgt
in berlin für befremden und
fassungslosigkeit und so appellierten
mehrere minister innen sich an die
demokratischen spielregeln zu halten und
zu warten bis alle stimmen ausgezählt
sind
lars bohnsack fasst die reaktionen
zusammen
die gesichter der minister sprechen
bände ringsum ist enttäuschung zu
erkennen offenbar hat kein mitglied des
bundeskabinetts mit diesem verlauf der
us wahl gerechnet
in der sprache der diplomatie klingt das
so die usa werden für uns ein wichtiger
partner bleiben egal wie die wahlen am
ende ausgehen werden allerdings wichtig
für uns ist das alles ausgezählt wird
und dass wir am ende dann auch ein
klares ergebnis haben dass sich aus
demokratischen wahlen in demokratischen
prozeduren ergibt etwas mutiger die
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer warnt vor den gefahren einer
hängepartie
das ist eine sehr exklusive situation es
ist eine situation von der die
expertinnen und experten zu recht sagen
sie kann zu einer verfassungskrise in
den usa führen und es ist etwas was uns
insgesamt sicherlich sehr gut morgen
muss noch deutlicher wird die opposition
weist amt gemacht das natürlich völlig
unmöglich man kann sich nicht mitten in
einer auszählung hinstellen und sich zum
sieger erklären dass verletzt jeden
jedes demokratische gefühl
einzig die afg hält sich mit kritik an
trump zurück im gegenteil man könne vom
us-präsidenten lernen
ich glaube was wir lernen können von
präsident trump ist germany first
deutsche interessen nationale interessen
wie der ernst nehmen das hat nämlich job
gemacht und das würde uns auch gut zu
gesicht stehen
dennoch die meisten politiker in berlin
sind kalt erwischt worden und stimmen
sich jetzt auf unsichere zeiten ein wohl
auch im kanzleramt
der mann sieht das politische berlin
erstaunlich ratlos schack und aller
banerjee hat sich die bundesregierung
denn gar nicht auf so ein szenario
vorbereitet was in der theorie sicher
schon aber in der praxis da gibt es
lücken denn die bundesregierung kennt
zwar auf der einen seite die probleme
die donald trump politik für sie
bereithält denn das haben wir in den
letzten vier jahren gesehen
trump hat einen internationalen
handelskrieg angezettelt er hat die nato
in frage gestellt und insbesondere
deutschland immer wieder für ein
mangelndes finanzielles engagement in
der nato kritisiert
und er hat auch internationale abkommen
gekündigt gleich mehrere die sehr
wichtig gewesen sind für die
internationale zusammenarbeit also das
hat die bundesregierung in den
vergangenen jahren zähneknirschend
ertragen und genau darin liegt das
problem
sie hat nicht gemeinsam mit der eu
konsequenzen gezogen
aus diesen ereignissen vielleicht auch
in der hoffnung dass ein möglicher
nachfolger von donald trump einiges
davon wieder rückgängig machen könnte
und jetzt wenn donald trump noch einmal
gewinnen sollte stünden also deutschland
und eu vor einigen sehr schwierigen
fragen wie kann die eu mehr
außenpolitisches gewicht gewinnen
braucht man für die verteidigung eine
europäische armee das ist ein
diskussionsvorschlag der in europa auf
dem tisch liegt und wie möchte man sich
positionieren im handelskrieg zwischen
china und den usa
da hat man bisher einen mittelweg
gefahren das würde sicherlich
schwieriger werden mit einer weiteren
amtszeit donald trump und noch mehr
druck aus den usa
das sind schwierige und teils sehr
grundsätzliche fragen die wir hier in
deutschland bisher kaum angefasst haben
geschweige denn innerhalb der eu und da
wären jetzt dann noch einige
hausaufgaben zu machen
ja die einschätzung von chuck unterleib
energy vielen dank dafür
nach wien zwei tage nach dem
islamistischen anschlag mit vier toten
werden immer mehr fragen laut warum etwa
wurde der täter vorzeitig aus der haft
entlassen
und was passierte mit einer information
der slowakischen polizei wonach der
täter in bratislava munition kaufen
wollte die regierung ist in
erklärungsnot
auf den straßen sind trauer und schock
noch gegenwärtig
wolf christian ullrich
tränen blumen und kerzen für die opfer
des terroranschlags ergreifende momente
die menschen erschüttert und bedrückt
die frage heute wie konnte das passieren
von den behörden erwarte ich mir schon
dass man auf leute die die
offensichtlich schon mit dem dschihad
islamismus sympathisieren dass man die
beobachtet und das sowas dann nicht
passiert die behörden in erklärungsnot
der täter war vor kurzem noch in haft
weil er sich dem anschließen wollte
bundeskanzler kurz kritisiert nun dass
er frühzeitig entlassen wurde
dann hätte dieser terroranschlag so
nicht stattfinden können
insofern war die entscheidung dass
dieser täter freigelassen wurde
definitiv falsch der täter war vorzeitig
freigekommen weil er im strafvollzug an
den guten eindruck hinterlassen hatte
eine fehleinschätzung hat sich geläutert
gezeigt er hat straftaten terroristische
handlungen im ausland verurteilt er
hatte offenbar die beteiligten
dementsprechend getäuscht in der
slowakei soll er versucht haben an
munition zu kommen
der slowakische geheimdienst hatte den
österreichischen verfassungsschutz
darüber informiert in der folge gab
innenminister neheimer heute
versäumnisse beim verfassungsschutz zu
aus diesem grund werde ich dem
nationalen sicherheitsrat heute
vorschlagen eine unabhängige
untersuchungskommission einzusetzen
die behörden ermitteln derzeit das
terrornetzwerk jenes schützen der den
schlimmsten anschlag der jüngeren
geschichte österreichs zu verantworten
hat minijobberinnen und mini jobber
gehören zu den größten verlierern der
korona pandemie nach einer studie des
deutschen instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung gab es im juni
850.000 weniger als ein jahr zuvor
sie hätten keinen anspruch auf
kurzarbeitergeld was zu einer
schnelleren entlassung führen so das diw
besonders viele geringfügig beschäftigte
gibt es in den corona geplagten branchen
gastronomie und veranstaltungen zur
coroner lage in deutschland die zahlen
bleiben hoch sie erreichen aber nicht
die rekordwerte der vergangenen woche
das robert-koch-institut registriert
binnen 24
sich stunden 17 1214 neue infektionen in
den vergangenen sieben tagen haben sich
im schnitt täglich 16.000 240 menschen
neu mit dem virus angesteckt gestern
waren es 17 1050 über weitere
entwicklungen berichtet julia schröter
in deutschland ist runtergefahren seit
vorgestern gelten massive kontakt
beschränkungen
doch die zahl der neuinfektionen bleibt
hoch das liegt daran dass diejenigen die
jetzt diagnostiziert werden sich meist
noch vor beginn des teil shutdowns
angesteckt haben erst in einigen tagen
kann man darauf hoffen dass die kontakt
bremse wirkung zeigt deutlich wachsend
ist die zahl derer die pro tag an cupid
19 sterben experten sind von der
entwicklung nicht überrascht die war
absolute erwarb war wir haben ja immer
vor diesen hohen infektionszahlen
gewarnt und haben gesagt diese hohen
infektionszahlen jetzt richtung 20.000
die werden sich erst in wochen auswirken
und so ist es wir sehen jetzt dass diese
situation sich füllen und das dann in
der folge auch die patienten sterben bei
denen die therapie leider nicht
erfolgreich ist
die zahlen waren es am ersten oktober
noch zwölf menschen die starben ging es
mit schwankungen hoch auf jetzt 1 151
todesfälle bisheriger höchststand der
zweiten welle die tendenz wohl erstmal
steigend die nächsten zwei bis vier
wochen werden einen anstieg sehen der
intensiv fälle und wahrscheinlich auch
der verstorbenen patientin an cupid 19
in deutschland das lässt sich
vorhersagen und alles darüber hinaus
hängt dann von den weiteren
infektionszahlen ab und die hängen wie
wir alle wissen von unserem verhalten
habe ein wert der zuletzt gesunken ist
ist der sogenannte erwert der angibt wie
viele menschen ein infizierter ansteckt
aktuell liegt er bei 0,98 doch das lka
warnt denn jetzt schon zu viel bedeutung
beizumessen
der wert sei nur ein faktor und das
momentane sinken könne auch einfach eine
schwankung seien viele bedenken hatte es
gegeben angesichts des ersten castor
transport seit neun jahren
und das mitten in der zweiten corona
welle doch die fahrt verlief reibungslos
der zug mit den sechs behältern
erreichte am morgen dass atommüll
zwischenlager im hessischen biblis und
zwar begleitet von protesten aber ohne
größere zwischenfälle
der müll kam aus der britischen
wiederaufarbeitungsanlage sellafield
stammte ursprünglich aus deutschen
kernkraftwerken
der hurrikan eta hat die karibik küste
von nicaragua in mittelamerika getroffen
mindestens drei menschen kamen ums leben
das ausmaß der schäden nach erdrutschen
und dauerregen ist noch unklar
zehntausende küstenbewohner waren zuvor
in sicherheit gebracht worden
die windgeschwindigkeiten erreichten in
spitzen bis zu 225 kilometer pro stunde
da und jetzt zum sport und zur champions
league und zu einem fußballfest
jedenfalls aus deutscher sicht katja
allerdings borussia mönchengladbach hat
wahrlich fußball vom allerfeinsten
geboten mit dem 6 0 gegen schachtjor
donetsk sicherte sich gladbach die
tabellenführung in gruppe b und holte
den höchsten auswärtssieg im europapokal
seit 47 jahren
gladbachs trainer rose und sein
portugiesischer kollege castro bei den
jetzt gegensätzliche stimmungslagen von
beginn an hellwach die gäste oft über
rechts den österreicher leiner und der
mitte players an player der franzose mit
dem ersten seiner drei treffer überlegt
verlängert gladbach zieht auf 2 0 davon
dann zeigt leer
er kann auch anders mit urgewalt zum 30
bis zur pause führen sie dann schon mit
vier zu null und kein bruch in der
zweiten hälfte schnelles konterspiel
maßgenaue pässe kein abseits player
setzt den schlusspunkt zum 6 0
auswärtssieg
seine spieler hätten fast alles richtig
gemacht so trainer rose als lohn die
tabellenführung aber die gruppenphase
bringt noch drei schwere spiele
ja gladbach also sechs tore und die
bayern genauso viele gestern abend beim
6 2 gegen rb salzburg die stimmung wird
nur getrübt durch die unruhe um die
vertragsverlängerung von david alaba
bleibt er oder bleibt er nicht die frage
um seine offene zukunft entwickelt sich
mehr und mehr zur posse das spiel
gestern auch mit unterhaltungswert
es war klar für den neutralen zuschauer
einfach ein topspiel und sehr
unterhaltsame spielt mit sehr viel tempo
das 62 hart umkämpft nach frühem
rückstand und lange gehaltenen 2 2 traf
jerome boateng in der 79 minute zum 3 2
danach noch seine lewandowski und in der
nachspielzeit ein anderes ein großer
schritt richtung achtelfinale
in der bundesliga wartet am samstag der
bvb und vielleicht gibt es bald klarheit
in sachen aller war
morgen starten deutschlands handballer
in die qualifikation für die em 2002 und
20 die gegner aus bosnien herzegowina
sind am abend am spielort in düsseldorf
gelandet zwangsläufig denn eigentlich
hatten sie eine verschiebung des spiels
beantragt weil sie wegen vieler kroner
fälle nur ein elf mann kader haben
antrag wurde aber abgelehnt das spiel
findet statt und das zdf überträgt live
von 16 uhr an
danke katja und wir haben noch die
ergebnisse von lotto
die gewinnzahlen lauten 27 17 32 43 45
und die superzahl 9 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 55 7
im gegensatz zu den unruhigen zeiten
erwarten uns wenigstens erwartet uns
wenigstens ruhiges herbstwetter mehr
dazu gleich von katja honnefer das war
es von uns danke für ihr interesse an
diesem spannenden tag und es geht hier
da ich weiter mit einem zdf spezial zur
auswahl
morgen sind wir dann wieder für sie da
punkt 19 uhr einen schönen abend noch
tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
vielleicht konnten auch sie gestern so
einen schönen sonnenuntergang erleben
und vielleicht hat das bei ihnen auch
heute geklappt denn viel sonnenschein
gab es ja heute hier zwischen berlin und
der mosel über norddeutschland zogen
einige regenschauer hinweg und dichtere
wolken gab es zwischen der lausitz und
dem oberrhein
die lösen sich jetzt in der nacht aber
mehr und mehr auf dann bildet sich zum
teil dichter nebel
dann müssen sie also aufpassen denn
dieser nebel hat nur geringe sichtweite
dichter sind die wolken an den alpen und
auch über norddeutschland gibt es einige
wolkenfelder bei west ham
es ist aber nicht nur nebel der die
nacht gefährlich macht sondern auch der
frost denn die temperaturen sinken
verbreitet auf plus 3 bis minus 3 grad
und dann gibt es bodenfrost es kann also
gefährlich glaubt seien auf den straßen
wenn sie unterwegs sein müssen passen
sie bitte auf bilder bleibt die nacht an
der donau und auch an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee und morgen steigen die
temperaturen auf 7 grad an den alpen und
bis auf 12 grad an der donau an der elbe
und an den küsten von nord- und ostsee
wenn sich der nebel und der hochnebel
morgen erstmal aufgelöst hat dann gibt
es viel sonnenschein am alpenrand
bleiben die wolken dagegen dichte und
auch über norddeutschland ziehen einige
wolkenfelder hinweg bei west wird und
mit diesem zu niebel neigenden
herbstwetter geht es auch in den
nächsten tagen weiter schön namen noch